hello everyone so i'm going to start
talking about three-dimensional curl and
to do that i'm going to start off by
taking the two-dimensional example that
i very first used when i was introducing
the intuition you know i talked about
fluid flow and i animated it here where
with this particular vector field you
see a certain counterclockwise rotation
on the right and a clockwise rotation on
the top so i'm going to take that vector
field which hopefully we have a little
bit of an intuition for and i'm going to
plop it into three dimensional space on
the x y plane so if i just take that
whole vector field and i copy it onto
the xy plane here's how it looks and the
vector spacing might be a little bit
different the choice of what sub sample
of points to use in displaying vectors
might be a little bit different but this
is the same field and it's actually
worth writing out how it's defined
in two dimensions this guy is a function
of x and y so it's a vector field
function of x and y
and what its components are
the first component is y cubed
minus 9y
and then the next one is x cubed
minus 9x
so now if i look at this guy and i say
let's start thinking about the fluid
rotation associated with it because it's
in three dimensions it's natural to
describe that rotation not just with a
number at each point you know with a
scalar value like the two-dimensional
curl gives us but instead to assign a
vector to each one
and when you do that when you associate
a vector to each different point in
space according to the fluid rotation
that would be happening there you get
something that looks like this
now this is kind of complicated because
there's two different vector fields
going on one of them all the vectors are
perpendicular to the xy plane so let's
just kind of take it piece by piece and
see if we can understand it so i've got
four different circled regions here
and one of them is this one on the right
where there's counterclockwise rotation
happening and if you think to your right
hand rule and i'll go ahead and bring in
the picture of the right hand rule here
where you imagine curling your fingers
around that direction of rotation and
the fingers of your right hand then you
stick out your thumb the direction your
thumb is pointing will be the direction
of vectors that describe that rotation
so if we do that here and if we um you
know you imagine curling your right
fingers around there and sticking up
your thumb you're going to get vectors
that point in the positive z direction
so this is why in that region you have
vectors pointing up positively in the z
direction they're telling you that as
you view this x y plane from above
there's counterclockwise rotation but
then what about at a different point
what about up here at the top where you
have clockwise rotation well there if
you imagine taking the fingers of your
right hand and curling them around that
direction of rotation your thumb is
going to be pointing straight down it'll
be kind of in the negative z direction
and we see that with this vector field
here where below that circle below that
point you have vectors pointing straight
down indicating that that's the
direction of rotation in that region so
if you do this at every single point and
you kind of get an understanding of what
the rotation is at every point and
assign a vector this is the field that
you're going to get and let's go ahead
and describe that with an actual
with a function because we know how to
compute the 2d curl at this point you
say if this whole thing if we
give names to the two different
component functions as p and q
then the curl the 2d curl of this guy
2d
curl
of the vector field v
as a function of x and y
what it equals is the partial derivative
of that second component with respect to
x so the partial of q
with respect to x
minus the partial derivative of that
first component with respect to y so
minus partial of p
with respect to y
and what we get when we do that
the partial of q with respect to x
so we take the partial derivative of
this with respect to x that just looks
like a derivative since there's only x's
in there and you get 3x squared
minus 9.
and i did i'd actually did this there's
another video where this is the example
that i do when you take this second
derivative of p with respect to y
you're taking the derivative of this top
part with respect to y
and that's
three y squared
minus nine
and what you can do is you can say this
minus 9 cancels out with that you know
minus minus 9. so these guys cancel
and what you ultimately get
is
3x squared plus
3 y squared
now what does this mean for the vector
field that we see here because this this
is a scalar valued quantity and yet the
vector field that i'm showing
with all these blue vectors indicating
rotation these are these are vectors
and because the rotation is happening
purely in the x y plane which is
perpendicular to the z axis all of these
vectors purely have a z component
so what you might say is that the curl
and i'm not going to say 2d curl but
actual curl of v
of v
as a function of x and y
is a it's not a scalar value but it's a
vector and it's going to be a vector
that describes these blue ones in the
pure z direction and since they're in
the pure z direction the x and y
components are 0 but that last component
is
the formula that we found that describes
the magnitude of the curl
3x squared
minus 3y squared
and this
let's see kind of running out of room
this here you could think of as kind of
a prototype to three-dimensional curl
because really this vector field v is
not quite a three-dimensional vector
field is it it only lives in the x-y
plane it only takes in x and y as input
points so what we want to do is start
extending this to say how can you make
this look like a three-dimensional
vector field and still kind of
understand the rotation as a
three-dimensional vector quantity and
that's what i'm going to continue doing
in the next video